just missed getting towed
by about
no joke 30 seconds
just missed getting towed by probably
30 seconds i came out to walk the dog
and uh let's see when jakey gets on here
i came out to walk the dog
and i was like huh and i saw this woman
a ticket on the car and i was like well
[ __ ] but i was like you know what
i didn't know they were giving tickets
again it's been six months without
getting a ticket
and uh hold on one second
got a ticket so you know whatever
so i'm coming out and this woman's
writing to take it dude i almost
i came within 30 30 seconds max of
getting towed
what where i'm in front of the crib
so they hadn't been given tickets right
right
they hadn't been given tickets and
but you know if you're moving you can or
you can or you're building something
you can buy like a tow away little spot
for the day
your hair is right yeah and
oh you were after the totally spot no no
where i had parked the car
three days ago somebody had permitted a
spot
so it had gone up and i just hadn't
walked by it or cared
and then i came out this morning dude
not kidding
she was looking at their license plate
and i was like oh you write me a ticket
i thought you weren't writing tickets
she goes we're not for this she looked
good pointed the sign though she goes
but if they buy it we gotta
dude when i ran back in to get my keys
the tow truck had just pulled up like i
missed it by 30 seconds
if i'd come out 30 seconds earlier i
would have just walked right past her
you want to see the tow truck yeah
they're taking that dude's car
right now wait somebody else pulled up
in the spot
man there was two of us were parked on
this one little
spot you know the one little spot in the
in the curb
he's getting towed right now man
oh yeah bummer but also
your boy got out of there 30 seconds to
go
what you think about that you got lucky
so [ __ ] lucky man holy [ __ ]
how's it going out there that's like
that's like when i got pulled over the
day before i left for london in february
and i was in a rental car and
some cop and followed me three blocks
because he said i ran a stop sign
when i did he literally watched me i
stopped and pointed at a pedestrian and
said are you crossing the road and she
said no
and i continued my turn dude followed me
for three blocks
and he goes well you got lucky today mr
wolf we got another call we'll see you
later and he hands me my stuff and
dips you get really lucky dude
you got like because if they want to
give you a ticket
oh there goes the car
you want to see it at the end of the
block
so here's what it is the movers there's
movers and the movers rent this little
spot
right yeah you know yeah they so they
bought they buy a permanent spot
yeah it's a temporary tow away for like
a day yeah yeah
yeah i know there's a dance lucky
as [ __ ]
dude i'm taking a w for the day this is
a dead this is a whole win for the day
don't you think yeah
you tell me i almost went
do you know on my second date with your
mo
with your mom i got the car towed
i think i've only ever gotten one ticket
on a date before
first date i ship my pants second date i
get the car towed
what did you guys take a bike home no
man we had to take this
a cab because there wasn't an uber to
this
sketchy ass tow place because we had
walked out of um
that place on santa monica and vine
i forget what that place was called but
it was we used to go see music and do
stand up there
and um santa monica live
santa monica and vine yeah it's one word
i forget what it was not the mint
dude i'm old i've been out in a long
time you know what i'm saying yeah
no i'm just trying to think of what's on
santa monica and vine
not for you for me
i'm curious um
we had to go pick up the car at this
sketch ass joint dude
do you remember the ticket
huh do you remember the only ticket i've
ever gotten while out on a date with a
girl
no can you give me a year uh
probably 2014 because i was able to
drive it was the years i was junior high
school
because i got my i got my license the
month before i turned 17.
i don't did you get a speeding ticket no
i was
me and taylor shorey went to a movie and
then we went to a lookout
and i parked the car at night hold on
super loud super loud why are you not
inside
super loud super loud can't hear you
though why is she having sucks
super loud i can't hear you super loud
okay i can hear you
why aren't you at home what
why aren't you at home old man you can't
hear regularly
i'm walking this guy man i thought you
already went out on the walk
no i i slept in ah
i'm walking this guy you want to see him
so i was
probably 17 and taylor shorey and i had
gone to a movie
and then i uh we drove to a lookout just
to look at
the view of la and i pulled up at 9 00
p.m
and there was a sign that said no
parking
or stopping from 9 00 pm to 6 00 am
and no joke two rangers pulled up
10 minutes late yeah and it was me and
another
me and taylor were at me and my
girlfriend at the time were actually not
doing anything we actually were just
looking at the view
the couple next to us was probably about
10 years older than us about 26 to 27
and they were rolling up weed and
[ __ ] in the car so they had a little
more of a
of a of a problem getting out of there
than we did
but i still got it i still got an 80
ticket you remember i came home
so upset that i got a ticket in your car
that's right
you remember that yeah did i pay for
that ticket
no i paid for that ticket before
i paid for that i paid good
somebody said living on indian
reservation police go crazy what does
that mean
i think nobody can live on indian
reservation unless you're
indians yeah well that's what i mean is
like unless you are yeah
well that's probably what she means dude
and then actually i'm sure
i'm sure they have their own yeah i
would assume that as well
dude poorly by the way oh
but you know like when it's when you
wake up and it's cold where you
sleep and you're living and you're like
well i'm gonna
yeah that's why you wear a thin long
sleeve and not a [ __ ] thermal
i mean why are you so testy because i
can't leave my goddamn hotel room
yeah when are you at a quarantine
whenever they tell me i'm negative
so like somebody just said i feel like
josh is facetiming himself
here that's hilarious
yeah i have my phone but
it's uh you do yeah no we don't get to
go out until we get the results back
that we're negative
so we're still just we're supposed to
get them yesterday or something
oh [ __ ] it should have been like
you were hoping it was a couple days ago
right they're supposed to be yesterday
yeah well i mean listen man there could
be worse things for so than somebody to
be paying for you to be in a hotel room
and bring any food you know
yeah well like like i said it's only
good when the food is good
take it easy um
your hair looks good dude it's crazy
wait hold on already watch this this is
the craziest
thing that i like to do it makes me
laugh right so it's like
it's here right but then watch this yeah
oh yeah you should get one i'm telling
you you should get a headband what's up
travis
i know you're doing a good time i need
to i need to get a headband just so i
can walk around like this all day
i'm saying dude did you
tell you about the dude who pulled over
here on rosewood and called your mom a
[ __ ]
um excuse me oh
my god man what do you need
okay so
i guess it was four or five days ago
we're walking down rosewood
and um so guys you know in our
neighborhood they
the city has made some of the streets
they call them slow streets
right right
so hold on one second your brother just
sent me a
text that looks important so just keep
talking i'm gonna have to put this on
pause for a second all right
all right here we go you good yeah yeah
yeah
um i'm so happy he didn't poop on a tree
yeah you chose not to believe me when i
warned you
oh so let me tell you about this guy
yeah so
who's calling mama [ __ ] i was thinking
about you i was so glad you weren't here
i would chase that car down and beat the
[ __ ] out of here well
we had a very interesting face-to-face
confrontation
well so first of all he
was speeding down the street and your
mom
screamed at him to slow down and flipped
him off
so he came to a stop and i was like oh
here we go
let's get it no i was like here this is
about to go down i don't really want
this to go down
but it was about to go down and um
he and i was just going to be like well
they're going to yell at each other
and this is quarantined and everybody's
a little testy
and then he rolled down the window and
said what [ __ ] and i was like
okay well now i have to get involved
yeah but uh
he pulled over and i leaned in the
window
and i was like hey man you know i
understand it's quarantine everybody's a
little bit testy but
you better watch your [ __ ] welsh
[ __ ] mouth that's not the word to
call her
and he was like she flipped me off i was
like you're speeding down a [ __ ]
twenty five street not twenty five mile
an hour dude it's slow street
there's cones up there's pictures of
kids walking and on bikes
like if you don't live on that street
you're not supposed to drive down and
when you drive down you're supposed to
do like five
dude get out of the car guess who
was not happy with that indiana jones
sir not
happy that's interesting yeah
man you get better score uh he just kept
the distance and i was just i kept
thinking i was like all right
am i do i want to end up on world star
today
i would have so here's the thing is like
i would have i'd beat the [ __ ] out of
somebody
but here's the deal i think at your age
i think my testosterone would have told
me to do the same thing
but at my age my testosterone was like
go home
man you don't need this kind of hassle
you know it's kind of a hassle look i'm
at a point now where
i clearly obviously if it's time to
fight we gotta fight
i don't wanna i'm not gonna throw a
first punch
you know i mean that's i'm past that
point in my life right
i mean honestly also i'm not throwing
first punch either but i'm gonna get
somebody riled up enough to throw a
first punch so that i can
oh he was riled up he was definitely
riled up i think
it was a [ __ ] but it was really weird
to see
in the past i'd just been like all right
i'll let go of indiana
and then i as indiana was chomping
around
i'd have been throwing a couple
haymakers myself
i'm so glad i'm past that point in my
life
what do you got there 80s rock band
well you said get a headband i brought
bandanas with me i love it
this is what my hair is just like i
don't know where to go with it
you guys i'm gonna go on top like that
they definitely would have caught kylo
ren's first punch that's right
that headband is awesome yeah i got well
i had it for coachella well i started
bringing bandanas to coachella to cover
my face because
when you're in the crowds the dust just
gets kicked up and so when like
literally i would go to blow my nose and
my mucus would be black because it was
just covered in dirt
oh my god so i i wear covers now when i
go to
chill which is this
what what was your favorite
tell me your favorite year of coachella
because you've been to three or four
right
first year 2015 is my favorite was that
was that also your favorite single
concert like who was your favorite
person to see
i honestly don't i honestly don't know
like
jack white was that year he still has to
be in my top five favorite sets i've
ever seen
yeah um he's on my [ __ ] he's on my
bucket list
that set was incredible it was [ __ ]
45 minutes to an hour i'm just pure
musical genius
it was [ __ ] intense
yeah and then
that same year that same day
um saw alt j that day
one of the great another another great
set
there they're quite objects good one
dude that day that saturday in 2015
i started at 3 p.m at the same stage i
didn't move
all day now 4 p.m sorry
milky chance was at 4 pm
which is another little like indie uh
alternative band i don't mind him
actually he's really good
but he was sick the day he was there so
his voice wasn't the best so it's kind
of me
but his music's not bad
what type of narcotics did you have in
you for the whole day uh this was back
when i only smoked wheat
so i mean i still also really only smoke
weed so
yeah yeah so i'm also listening to music
in the background
um but that same day this is not
by the way this is not my brother this
is my son
um first was milky chance at four
five thirty was hosier seven o'clock
seven o'clock was alt j nine o'clock was
jack white
and eleven was the weekend i didn't move
i stayed at that same stage for five
straight sets
that's crazy i didn't move i didn't have
to move there was no reason for me to
move
has weezer ever been up there somebody's
saying weezer was there in 2019 and i
got to
watch them as well i got to tell you my
favorite
surprise band surprise show it was a
surprise show like nobody knew was
happening
i just didn't know flagging molly's
yours huh
um i
bought tickets uh before they put out
the green album
um to see them at the whiskey and i
bought tickets for me
and jonathan and dan and the whiskey
girl
dude they played the blue album from
opening song to the end it's amazing
what
maybe 400 people in there i don't know
what fits in there yeah this
doesn't fit more than 400 people yeah i
got to tell you
well it was pretty amazing
i was going to tell you a funny story
about that night but then i realized i
can't tell you that story
what um what yeah
can't tell it i don't can't tell it to
me now or just can't tell to be period
probably period
guess song just go ask jonathan instead
maybe jonathan was there was he there
first name you said you said i literally
bought tickets for me jonathan and the
brother i don't
yeah i don't know if he we'll see i
don't know if he remembers maybe
well i'm not sure yeah i'd have to think
about what was happening if he was
involved
um yeah
uh somebody and is that your so your
favorite
that was your favorite show but was that
your favorite concert come on man
not eating that um because you saw
some other shows well not unfortunately
but you know a lot of my concert
memories are with taylor so i'm trying
to think of also concert memories that
don't make me sad
um right so like oh um
in 2015 as well when i went to lsu for
one semester i also
attended austin city limits thank you
for that
um when i attempted or when i attended
austin city limits
when drake performed on the first night
he had a guest performer come out
and to this day i've still never seen
him live
he is probably my favorite artist right
now maybe of all time
and i've still never seen him in concert
wait i don't understand oh he had
somebody else come out farm
drake no drake came out and did four or
five songs and he said guys
it's [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] i'm gonna take
a quick water break but while i take a
water break enjoy this guy and they
dropped
and he dropped no role models and j cole
comes
sprinting out on stage and i was like
and i was like who's your guy dude i
[ __ ] i was with jackson and alyssa
i wish you could ask jackson but i was i
jumped on him i was punching him like i
was i was freaking
out i mean straight
straight just straight 100
panic i didn't know what to do i didn't
know what to do
straight 100 panic do you want do you
want to hear a funny story
sure okay i'm on melrose
at lauriga okay and i your mom and i
when these were cool
you we at one point wore those big thick
coffees yeah you weren't a stupid you
wore the stupid black bracelet for like
10 years
but do you remember those the cuffs you
wore them for 10 years dude
not 10 years dude but it may have seemed
like 10 years at your age but it was not
10 years
so it felt like 10 years so
um i was in baton rouge right
that's what rouge and uh
we're performing and
you ready for this i walk in the guy
says to me he goes uh
he's going over the show for tonight and
he goes do you need anything for your
show
no i don't need it and he said uh
where are you putting the bird
he goes we've never had a bird in here
before and i told him i go i don't have
a bird dude
and he goes what's that thing on your
wrist for isn't that where the bird
lands
i don't know man that's enough he
clowned you bro
i don't wear a [ __ ] fart i start with
the birdlands [ __ ] he
[ __ ] clowned you
it was so funny that is
awesome it's like the perfect response
to that
yeah it was so funny hey man we've never
had a comedian
slash bird wrangler what do you mean
he was so confused he was
like so that it was it made me
laugh man and i definitely didn't wear
the
the falcon claw to the show that night
that's also the only place i've ever
thrown up on stage
why did you throw up on stage they kept
sending me shots and i told them if you
keep sending me shots
i'm gonna throw up and they what
this is where i was in my career at the
time they apparently thought watching me
throw up was funnier than me doing my
act
come on man so
that's what happened i only remember
honestly i can only account
for doing like one tequila shot with you
ever in my entire life
maybe we've only done one well two
technically it was four typically was
four but it was two double shots
was it two double shots it was two
doubles
in cleveland oh that's right
oh we may have done one shot together
at my birthday in arizona
oh yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah we did do one shot there too
yeah
maybe we'll see you know
um i'm not a drinker dude i do you know
dude who are you talking to you huh
i said who are you talking to i get that
from you too i'm not a i'm not a drinker
either
i'm not a drinker hold on we're not true
somebody asked who's my favorite
stand-up comedian
uh uh so tyler goes if you had a [ __ ]
parrot on stage that repeats [ __ ] that
would be that just said i'll wrestle you
that's so funny
so yeah in washington when i started
when i started doing stand-up in
washington there was a gig
that had a bird on stage
um they had like part of the it was a
restaurant but they were they did a
one-nighter
and the restaurant had parents and the
parents were on stage
and they didn't move the parrots from
stand up
so you would do stand up no and there
would be a bird behind
a bird behind oh my god hell no it was
funny
i went up there with joey diaz once and
he could he went
off on that bird this [ __ ] bird to
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what's funny he's
the only guy who i think would verbally
attack the bird
it was hilarious let's see who people
are saying are their favorite comics
that's really awesome yeah
gabriela's
doing that show together so yeah they're
both super funny
yeah no i think it is funny
i have a question for you just because
yeah because i have friends
who i have a lot of friends who don't
think kevin hart is funny
and uh you know for me a lot of them are
like it's just
the it's their their reasoning is i
don't think he's that funny all he does
is scream and move his hands
and all white people say he's funny
because it's like
it's almost like if you say you think
he's funny it it
it helps your appearance i don't know
something like that i'm like dude kevin
is [ __ ]
funny like i don't i
i don't i comedy is 100 subjective so
we'll start with that that's true
but kevin hart
has been funny for a long [ __ ] time
i think hardest working dudes he keeps
his comedy pretty clean
he tells ridiculous stories yep like
it's i i think kevin hart is super super
that story about him
at a basketball camp with kobe bryant is
the funniest eighth
four minute video i've ever seen in my
entire life
yeah there's no have you seen that
yeah dude there's no getting around he's
funny and he's got a great sense of
humor about himself he doesn't take
himself seriously like
no holy [ __ ] but i do think it's funny
somebody mentioned they said
when somebody asked who their favorite
comic was
people just started mentioning comics
that aren't me robin williams tim
dillon joe coy gabriela glazier it's
hilarious
um by the way
for those of you who like tim dillon
he's super funny what are you talking
about i know you're a humor and we'll
get along well
that dude's [ __ ] up
he's really dude his his first joke
on the spade show was a 911 joke and i
was like oh my god dude
yeah dude came out swinging
it was great but he's good he's he's
such a
but he's again he's like a real unique
voice
super dope he's super um he's super fun
what's going on so tell me what the plan
is with the hair for the next month
this
i like it someone said pete davidson is
your favorite comedian
i honestly don't find him that funny
again suggested this you know
everybody has their own thing but i just
never really found him that fine
not my thing either but you know i think
that's more
hey hey dennis is his favorite community
uh i'm not like generationally
his humor doesn't hit me at all it
doesn't hit me you know uh dennis says
his favorite comedian is josh wolfe
good answer i mean finally somebody on
my page picked me
i know right
yeah i think comedy is the best part
about comics and i'm not offended when
people don't think i'm funny and i'm not
offended when people don't think i'm
their favorite and
comedy's subjective man like if you're
out there
you're not going to fit everybody into
the one square hole so it doesn't bother
me at all
right um someone said fortune fortune
theme sir is [ __ ]
great and somebody said hey he's a uh
someone said pete davis is a funny actor
not so much stand up guys that's why
it's called acting doesn't mean you're
actually funny
it means people write things for you i
think he's a good writer dude
i think he's really writing good stuff
for snl
um i'm not knocking pete man like
he's just not my sense of humor but he's
somebody's
and and who am i to say he's obviously
done a little better in his career than
i have so it's not like i can knock this
dude you know
yeah i mean 100 um someone said will
ferrell
hey i can quote the whole step brothers
movie right now
or yeah blades of lord we pick one
but not a comedian but not a comedian
100
not a canadian not a comedian uh but
funniest [ __ ] yeah and this oh my god
so i'm i can't i'm not so much like
carlos mencia i'm gonna just not even
man whatever they doesn't bother me at
all whatever they wanna think is cool
you know um oh you saw us live
well thanks i appreciate that joy um
please yeah super funny again
not a comedian i somebody just said
up church is a good youtube comedian i
just have to tell you guys
i don't know what that means youtube
comedian
i've seen a lot of people who have
called themselves youtube comedians and
then when they get on stage
so i don't work like a comedian is like
you get on stage with a mic in front of
an audience and tell jokes
if you're making videos on youtube
you're skips you make sketches you're
not a comedian you're just not a
comedian yet
and so it's so different and the skill
set like i can't do what they do
i'm terrible at writing sketches but
they also can't do what you do
yeah but there's like there's no shame
in that game no 100
but but it's but you have to be able to
uh differentiate
the difference between someone who can
act and write and skit and skits and
sketches
than someone who can be a stand-up comic
there's a huge difference but
i feel like it almost not
i feel like it's almost an insult to you
guys for the people who call themselves
comedians who are just like made their
cup you know made their uh living based
off of making funny videos on like vine
or
instagram yeah i know some people get
the boxing gyms open
i know some people get a little uptight
about that you know me dude i don't
i know you don't call yourself whatever
the [ __ ] you want
i don't give a [ __ ] like you can call
yourself spaceman x and walk on stage
and do whatever the [ __ ] are you doing
it doesn't
you know um someone said uh i agree but
is will farrell not a comedian
he's a he's a comedic actor but he's not
a stand-up comic
yeah he's somebody said i accidentally i
accidentally slapped my nuts
who has the best special again all
subjective
um buddy i'm about to walk into
the store i don't want to be a guy on
the phone
i love you i'll call you back a little
later today all right
talk to you hey everybody i'm going to
be on fighter in the kid today go check
it out
jacob wolf ha do you want i can hop back
down here
after i get my coffee if you want you
just hanging out yeah i'm just here
all right i'll right when i get the copy
i'll call you i'll i'll we'll get back
on here
you're only going to have one hand call
me when you get home
oh that's right i love you love you jim
jeffries
see you everybody